all right let's get into hatred mail for
the week if you don't have any clue what
hatred mail is here's a quick explainer
on it the right of the people to keep
and bear hates shall not be infringed
patriot man written by Patriots who hate
David Pakman because America because
freedom
all right homophobia is no rare
occurrence in hatred mail but there's a
very particular phrase that is a
homophobic phrase in this hatred mail
that is sort of a new approach let's
take a listen day baby WTF ru Pakman is
such a betta loll what a straight
Alex Jones can intellectually as
well as physically kick this beta's ass
guaranteed and look at his nerd ass
lispy friend with the I'm cool goatee
LMFAO these beta Cox circle check each
other for sure how much are they paying
you to spread propaganda end of by the
mainstream media that's right and of by
the mainstream media how can someone be
a straight I mean the homophobia is
disgusting and the fact that it's either
the show is bad because I'm Jewish or
the show is bad because I'm perceived to
be gay but what does it mean to be a
straight I think he means like a
straight up like I'm like I'm only
oh yes huh
that's my interpretation it's pretty
vile right yeah yeah well
congratulations you've made it on to
hate revile and at first I was thinking
I'm not a nerd and I don't have a lisp
and then I realized I think he's talking
about Louis cuz I always go cheatin yeah
Louis of course has a slight Lisp
although he has always denied it but
listen folks we know that he does very
very slight and he did have a goatee for
like the last year or two of the program
so this person must have must have been
responding this to an old video maybe
sure and maybe at this point with all
the changes of the show that's been
going on over the past year or so maybe
now he would like it maybe now he would
love the show yeah yeah if he
accidentally saw the show again he
probably love the show turn hatred mail
into something positive you can use the
coupon code hey tree at forty at david
pakman.com slash membership